بها عبرت الصين عن عمليها ان تلتقي مع
الولايات المتحده في منتصف الطريق وعرب
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه عن عمله ان
تدار الخلافات بين الجانبين بشكل صحيح
لتجنب سوء التقدير على حد تعبيره
ان تلتقي الولايات المتحده مع الصين في
منتصف الطريق بروح الاحترام المتبادل وان
تلعب دورا مسؤولا في الحفاظ على الاستقرار
والتنميه في العالم
والجزيره بالاحرى وجد وقت مرحبا بك وجد
ماذا على جندت هذه القمه وعلى ماذا تراهن
الولايات المتحده في همم فيها
نعم بالاضافه الى اللاعب دور اكبر على
صعيد احلال السلام والاستقرار في منطقه
دول الاسيان جنوب شرق اسيا
وكذلك
المساعده هذه الدول في التنميه الاقتصاديه
تحقيق انماء الاقتصادي هناك ايضا بنود
تتعلق بالتعاون الامني مع دول العصيان
وكذلك تعزيز الشراكه الاقتصاديه مع هذه
الدول وتعميق علاقاتها بحسب ما قاله
مستشار رئيس الامريكي للامن القومي تشيك
صالبا طبعا همم الرئيس الامريكي الذي سوف
يخاطب همم القمه الامريكيه قمه الولايات
المتحده والرابطه امم جنوب شرق اسيا بعد
نحو ساعتين سوف يؤكد على هذه الاهداف التي
جاء من اجلها ايضا سوف يؤكد رغبه الولايات
المتحده في زيزي تحالفاتها مع دول هذه
المنطقه هناك حقيقه على هامش هذه القمه
هناك اجتماعات اخرى مهمه وتصب في همم ما
ترى الولايات المتحده انه مصلحه دوليه
وليس مصلحه امريكيه وحسبها مثال على ذلك
اجتماع الرئيس مع قاده اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه يوم الغد الولايات المتحده تريد
من هذا الاجتماع
باعلى مستوى من التعاون الامني على
المستوى الثلاثي ما بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان في منطقه الشرق
اسيا طبعا والهدف من ذلك همم كل من الصين
مواجهه النفوذ الصيني في تلك المنطقه
وكذلك همم الانشطه التي تقوم بها كوريا
الشماليه هذه الانشطه او التهديدات بحسب
وصف همم
سوف تكون اجنده الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
هنا وايضا ضمن اجندته خلال اجتماعيه
المرقه المرتقب للمره الاولى وجها لوجه مع
الرئيس الصيني الاثنين المقبل في بالي على
هامش قمه العشرين الرئيس بايدن بحسب جيك
سولفن يود ان يوجه للرئيس الصيني
رساله مفادها بان على الصين ان تلعب دورا
بناءا فيما يتعلق بانشطه كوريا الشماليه
ولان تلك الانشطه لا تهدد فقط امن
الولايات المتحده بل المنطقه برمتها وقال
ان همم الولايات المتحده لا تعلم كيف
سيكون الرد الصيني وما اذا كانت الصين
تلعب دورا بناء لكن اذا استمرت الانشطه
لكوريا الشماليه على نهجها في الولايات
المتحده سوف تعزز وجودها العسكري في تلك
المنطقه المنطقه